dr devries the biggest fan of tabletop  games at site 19 decided to give scp-914  the clockworks one complete core set of  the dungeons and dragons books in 3.5 e  he only tested it on fine with the  result being one large book measuring  two inches by 11 inches by nine inches  titled the complete dungeons and dragons  core set 3.5 e upon inspection the book  was determined to be a combined version  of all three previous books written in  millwitch english font dr devries  appended a note to the file on this test  saying i'll be keeping this in the  lounge if anyone wants to use this i'll  also be holding a game next tuesday  bring your own character sheets